Speaker 1: I have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I asked on the show yesterday if you are a
non right winger.
And you have a my pillow pillow, please let
me know, like the pillow can't possibly be
that good, right?
It seems to me that if you buy a my pillow
pillow, it's political.
I got a couple of voicemails about it.
Take a listen to this first one.
Speaker 5: Hey, my pillows is a good pillow
period, no matter what he thinks and also
is pretty flaky putting advertising on this
at the end of the thing, right.
Pretty sick of you kind of thing, but my pillow
is a good pillow, period.
This is how calling from the great state of
Texas.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Howard from Texas likes the pillar.
Here's one other one who says I have a pillow.
It's actually not that great.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
This is Jack from New Jersey.
And recently on your show, you put out a call
to members of your audience.
Yes.
Who are on the left who own in my pillow.
And let me tell you, I'm as lost as they come.
And I don't own just one might go around to
my pillows.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Alive in my bed right now with both my pillows
giving them a test run.
And if I may say.
They're they're just tell us I don't remember
when I got that, I don't even remember where
I got them, but I have them.
They're not as good as the Tempur-Pedic pillows
I have.
They're trying to say hello.
OK, what do you recommend?
They're just a total.
Speaker 1: Thank, David.
Just a pillow.
Not exactly a ringing endorsement.
All right.
So that there is I'm actually surprised that
the number of people in the audience that
have these pillows, we have a great bonus
show for you today.
Kim Potter, the officer who killed Dontae,
right.
Has been charged with second degree manslaughter.
OK, we will talk about that on today's bonus
show.
Democrats are now pushing for Republican support
on Asian-American hate crimes legislation.
Will they get it?
Unclear.
And the Biden administration is pushing for
a major expansion of offshore wind energy.
You are starting to see Republicans say, oh,
but it doesn't look good to look offshore
off of our beautiful beaches and what, you
know, into the into the waterways and seeing
wind turbines, that is now what they are saying.
So we will talk about that.
This is a great push.
It would be great to expand that.
All of those stories and more.
And I will be joined by producer Pat on today's
Bonas show, get instant access by signing
up at Join Pakman dot com.
Unidentified: I'll see you on.